euh avec notre dernière invité pour
cette émission spéciale les sia
Vassilenko député ukrainienne vous
intervenez en fait depuis le début de
cette invasion à grande échelle sur les
antennes du monde entier sur notre
antenne plusieurs fois vous êtes senti
une mission je pense de communiquer sur
ce qui se passerait réellement en
Ukraine est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que l'Occident a compris
quelque chose qu'il ne comprenait pas
peut-être avant moi mes collègues on
essaye de faire les Occidentaux
comprendre à comprendre beaucoup plus et
donner beaucoup plus qu'ils ont donné
j'espérais vraiment que cette
compréhension pourrait arriver avant le
24 février et qu'on pourrait prévenir
beaucoup des morts de blessés
qu'on a aujourd'hui ici on voit autour
de nous les expositions sur la guerre
dans le don de basse pendant cette
guerre quelles ont été les erreurs qui
ont été faits par les l'Occident
vous savez c'est une guerre qui est
commencé en 2014 donc il est en avant on
est dans la dixième année de guerre de
la Russie contre l'Ukraine c'est une
garde agression c'est vraiment c'est pas
que le Dombas c'est pas la garde du bas
c'est pas la guerre du Christ mais c'est
la guerre de la Russie contre le crâne
et alors ce que pourrait être fait de
différent à vrai dire on pourrait armer
quand même beaucoup plus tôt on pourrait
comprendre que la Russie est agresseur
impératiste beaucoup plus tôt et vous
avez j'ai vu un tweet ce matin où vous
avez dit aussi que le 24 février le
monde n'avait pas confiance que
l'Ukraine était capable de résister
n'est-ce pas est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que la confiance
aujourd'hui
j'étais en France je pense la deuxième
semaine de février 2022 et j'avais plein
de réunions de rencontre avec des
représentants du gouvernement français
le ministère de la Défense surtout ils
m'ont dit tous la même chose vous savez
il y a les rapports de l'intelligence
qui montrent que les riches amassent les
troupes et que on doit s'attendre à une
attaque je disais oui bien sûr les
Russes font ça tout le temps pendant les
8 dernières années qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire et me disait non mais vous devez
négocier asseyez-vous à la table avec
Poutine négocier en notre mot donnez-lui
le territoire et pour moi d'entendre
cela c'était vraiment déprimant je vous
dis j'ai l'impression aujourd'hui
pourtant que il y a encore aujourd'hui
des gens qui disent que ce n'est pas
réaliste de penser que l'Ukraine peut
chasser les forces russes de tous son
territoire que les ambitions de
l'Ukraine ne peuvent pas être réalisés
par la voie militaire et encore
aujourd'hui qu'il faut négocier quel est
votre réponse aux gens qui disent cela
aujourd'hui
moi je suis réaliste et j'aimerais que
ces gens-là soient réalistes aussi
qu'ils voient la vérité pour ce qu'il a
sans le repoussement total de la Russie
de l'armée russe du territoire ukrainien
on va pas avoir une paix on va pas avoir
une paix long terme en Ukraine en Europe
nulle part au monde et ça c'est quelque
chose de réaliste pourquoi exactement
les Russes ils ont leur appétit ils ont
leur appétit impérialistes Poutine il
voit à la grande Legrand empirus et ça
doit être surtout avec le crâne dans cet
empire mais il va pas s'arrêter à
l'Ukraine il va continuer il y a les
autres pays de l'Europe de l'Est que
Poutine considère comme partie de
l'empire russe et si on apaise les
dictateurs si on apaise les dirigeants
autoritaires qu'est-ce que ça nous donne
ça nous donne des guerres ça nous donne
des souffrances ça nous donne des pertes
on a vu tout en Europe dans les années
du
21e siècle avec la deuxième guerre
mondiale on a lu cela avec la Géorgie on
a vu cela avec la Syrie les Russes qui
sont apaisés les Russes qui qui sont
laissés faire comme il va il ils ont un
sentiment qui continuait est-ce que vous
avez une idée de à quoi pourrait
ressembler la victoire à quoi devrait
ressembler la Russie après une victoire
éventuelle de l'Ukraine j'espère avoir
un voisin
démocratique un voisin où les dirigeants
et le gouvernement respectent les droits
humains où il n'essaie pas à chaque
opportunité de faire des exceptions des
lois internationales surtout de la
Convention des européennes des droits
humains j'espère avoir un voisin qui
comprend le tort que le gouvernement de
Poutine a fait et qui a le courage de
venir et de demander pardon à la nation
ukrainienne et vous avez parlé de
démocratie en réalité vous êtes député
d'opposition le parti rollos mais vous
soutenez le président zellenski depuis
le 24 février 2022 comment fonctionne en
ce moment exactement la démocratie en
Ukraine par exemple moi j'étais au
Parlement ce matin j'étais aussi au
Parlement hier parce qu'on était en
session on discutait des lois ont voté
donc
pendant toute cette année c'était plus
ou moins la même chose le Parlement
ukrainien fonctionne toujours on est en
unité totale quand ça concerne les
questions de la défense de la sécurité
ukrainienne du repoussement de
l'agression russe sur les questions
internationales mais quand ça concerne
comment le pays fonctionne
selon le secteur d'éducation le secteur
de la santé le économique on a bien sûr
tous nos différents opinions et on en
discute on en discute en commission en
ligne on en discute dans la salle du
Parlement et on vote comme on fait en
France par exemple on ne va pas voter je
suppose il y aura pas d'élection
possible on ne craignent pendant qu'il y
a la loi martiale qui est en vigueur
c'est vrai la loi martiale elle est
toujours en regard elle va continuer
jusqu'à ce qu'elle a victoire
ukrainienne et c'est vrai que on
pourrait pas avoir des élections
normalement on devrait avoir les
élections en Ukraine en octobre à cette
année là 2023
normalement selon notre loi la campagne
électorale devrait commencer en été 2023
mais si on aura toujours la loi martiale
ce ne serait pas possible
pensons à la dernière année où il y a eu
les élections parlementaires 2019 quand
vous avez été élu à cette époque là
vendredi merzelinski et son équipe ils
avaient une position de vouloir négocier
avec la Russie pour essayer de mettre
fin à la guerre dans le don de base et
ce qui était opposé
monsieur zelienski disait que il était
pour le mieux naïf ou pour le pire pro
russe est-ce que vous pensez que
lui-même a changé de point de vue ou
c'est les Ukrainiens en fait qui
s'étaient opposés à lui ce qui s'était
proposé à lui qu'il avait mal compris à
l'époque je suis sûr qu'il a changé
d'avis il a essayé il a fait les
meilleurs efforts de trouver quelque
chose qui pourrait être négociable mais
quand ça venait au territoire ukrainien
aux gens ukrainiens à leur vie ça c'est
pas négociable donc il a abandonné ses
idées et je pense que ça tournait
beaucoup l'opinion que la nation
ukrainienne a de son président lui-même
il a réellement découvert que la Russie
n'était pas comme il s'imaginait
vraiment à des
différents sentiments au début en 2019
moi par exemple qui avant d'entrer dans
le Parlement d'être élu moi je faisais
beaucoup de travail avec les combattants
les anciens combattants surtout
je comprenais ce qui était les Russes
surtout de parole des décisions de ces
femmes qui qui ont vu cela sur la ligne
de front sur la frontière sur la ligne
de combat donc moi j'avais pas
d'illusion que c'est pas possible de
négocier avec je faisais ce genre de
travail depuis 2014 donc pour sa grande
ma vie j'étais dédiée qui est vraiment à
aux efforts de la guerre du repoussement
de des avancements agressifs russes mais
bien sûr que c'était pas évident pour
tout le monde et comme je dis il a
essayé et il n'a pas pu faire
sa position a été vraiment à
certaines vraiment fortes une position
ukrainienne les Russes n'ont pas accepté
ils ont décidé d'escaler de mettre plus
de pression ça n'a pas marché l'Ukraine
a commencé de se battre de repousser
tout cela et maintenant on a tous les
Occidentaux qui qui nous soutiennent
tout le monde démocratique derrière nous
on a les livraisons des armes qui
arrivent j'espère qu'ils vont arriver au
plus vite possible dans des noms
beaucoup beaucoup plus grands qu'on
puisse repousser les Russes vraiment en
finale peut-être même par la fin de
cette année-là
et peut-être beaucoup d'ukrainés aussi
qui ont traversé ce même trajectoire
parce qu'il y a un an le pays comptait
encore pas mal de gens dans les opinions
pourraient être qualifiés de prorus
n'est-ce pas
à ce moment j'aimerais concentrer sur
les chiffres qu'on a donc on a 87 % de
sucre rien qui soutiennent l'accession
de l'Ukraine à l'Union européenne on a
86% des Ukrainiens qui soutiennent
l'accession de l'Ukraine à l'OTAN donc
ça veut dire déjà beaucoup beaucoup j'en
connais beaucoup de
Ukrainiens qui qui
ont ouvert les yeux en quelque sorte
que c'est la Russie et les Russes sous
le gouvernement de Poutine merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je vous passe la